remembering some of the victims today
they're being described this way
truly one of a kind a hard-working
well-regarded young man
a beautiful soul with a warm and loving
heart and a father
who represents all things love just some
of the ways that the 10 victims from the
colorado supermarket shooting are being
remembered this morning
by the friends and the family that they
left behind who are in still
so much pain today the dead range in age
from 20 to 65 years old
the latest losses in this country and
crimes committed by people using
semi-automatic weapons among them
responding police officer
supermarket employees and a
grandfather-to-be
we are also learning new details this
morning about the shooting suspect he
has been identified as 21-year-old ahmad
al-aliwi alissa he faces 10 counts of
first-degree murder following monday's
rampage and we have full coverage from
boulder including our lead national
correspondent david begno
on the investigation but we're going to
start with jonathan vigliotti
and stay with the families of those we
lost jonathan good morning to you
good morning to you tony this is the
patrol car officer talley
drove to the scene it's parked here this
morning in front of the police
department
as part of a growing memorial and when
you look at it
it's hard not to think of the nine other
victims people tally was trying to save
that also didn't make it he was a really
smart kid
he was training to be an airline pilot
he wanted to be a commercial airline
pilot that was his dream
to dean schiller 20 year old denny stong
was just getting started
he was a good boulder kid you know he
was it was a little bit
sheltered you know we we go about our
lives thinking that
you know we can trust society to take
care of us and he was definitely one of
those people he definitely trusted and
was super friendly and helpful the two
had spent monday morning
hiking before riding to king supers
together to pick up lunch
they got separated and planned to meet
up at schiller's car
schiller was already outside when he
heard the shots
i assumed he was right behind me so he
must have been at the entrance as
the shooter was coming in schiller began
filming we've got
injured parties on the ground
9-1-1 now people documenting live on
youtube
what happened for the next three hours
as
thousands watched at home we got people
down inside king supers
at that point he didn't know stong was
among the victims
i have my moments when i'm able to hold
it together and
a lot of times when family come to visit
or close friends
it becomes a bit more emotional because
we all share in the grief together
sharing that grief are the friends and
family members of the other
nine victims kevin mahoney's pregnant
daughter erica
called him her hero and wrote you are
always with me
51 year old officer eric talley was
first on the scene
rushing to save those inside we spoke to
his father over the phone
my granddaughter told me on the phone
that dad was dead
and it slowly sink in
he told us how his son joined the force
when he turned
40 leaving a comfortable desk job to
protect the citizens of boulder
did it surprise you to learn that your
son was not only the first to arrive
here on the scene at this supermarket
but also the first to put his life on
the line
it did not surprise me at all he was
that's who he was but talley said his
son a father of seven children
would be embarrassed to be called a hero
and that he just consider it
part of his job how do you want your son
to be remembered
as a father as a police officer
who wanted to serve and a person with a
good heart
because he truly did have a good heart
and officer tally's father said
something that struck me he said
initially as you can imagine he was
enraged he was angry to hear about his
son but then
he leaned into his faith and he chose
forgiveness he says he forgives the man
who killed his son because anthony as he
put it
the world needs more forgiveness and
kindness
jonathan thank you each one of those
stories i'm thinking of the face of
denny song who looks
so young in those photographs he's 20
years old
you know it's just devastating i just
think as the sounds you hear today are
grief meeting outrage yes
because we all have been here before and
you know what jonathan said he said
something struck him everything about
that story strikes me everything
about that forgiveness is a very
powerful message from that family
it really is but but i marvel at when
people are there this close to the
tragedy
actually that they find it yeah yeah i
agree forgiveness doesn't mean
helplessness though
things can be done and that's the next
conversation that's right